aortic valve stenosis is a condition in
which the aortic valve is narrowed
the aortic valve is located between your
heart's main pumping chamber the left
ventricle and the major artery the aorta
that carries blood to your body
the stenosis is caused by valve leaflets
that are thickened or calcified and
fused
the view from above shows the valve
opening is smaller than
normal the diseased leaflets cannot move
correctly resulting in poor blood flow
through the valve which causes pressure
to build in the left ventricle
if not treated this condition can damage
or weaken the heart muscle over time
symptoms may include
shortness of breath
extreme progressive fatigue
weakness
lightheadedness and dizziness when
walking or standing
abnormal swelling in the legs and
abdomen and difficulty breathing due to
fluid retention in the lungs
an echocardiogram or cardiac ultrasound
is a diagnostic test that uses sound
waves to view structures of the beating
heart such as the chambers or valves
a device called a transducer is placed
on the chest wall and sound waves are
transformed into images and video which
are used to evaluate your heart's
function and visualize structural
details
blood flow is recorded with a technique
called color doppler
the echocardiogram shows the strength of
the heart muscle squeeze and if any of
your heart valves are too tight stenotic
or too leaky regurgitation
this information helps your physician
choose an appropriate treatment
transcatheter aortic valve replacement
or tavr is a treatment for aortic valve
stenosis which is a narrowing of the
aortic valve as shown here
the stenosis is caused by valve leaflets
that are thickened or calcified and
fused
the view from above shows the valve
opening is smaller than normal
the diseased leaflets cannot move
correctly resulting in poor blood flow
through the valve and causing pressure
to build in the left ventricle
this can damage or weaken the heart
muscle over time
a 3d ct scan is performed in advanced to
help plan and map out the procedure
during the procedure a guide wire is
inserted through a small incision
usually into an artery of the leg
advance to the aorta and passed through
the stenotic valve
a special catheter that contains a
collapsed replacement valve is then
inserted
once the physician has the new valve
positioned correctly within the diseased
valve the heart is sometimes paste
pacing makes the heartbeat so fast it
cannot pump blood for a few seconds
thereby allowing safe and effective
valve deployment
to deploy the valve two techniques are
commonly used
in one the catheter is pulled back and
the valve expands into place
and in the other a balloon expands the
valve
after valve expansion pacing is turned
off and the heart beats normally
with a new heart valve working properly
the catheter and guide wire are then
removed and blood flows freely out of
the heart
although the transcatheter aortic valve
replacement or tavr procedure is safe
there are some risks to be aware of when
considering a tavr
in a timbre procedure a special catheter
that contains a collapsed replacement
valve is inserted
note that the openings to the coronary
arteries are close to this area and
blocking these openings is a risk
once the physician has the new valve
positioned correctly within the diseased
valve the heart is paced
note that the heart's electrical system
is close to this area and interfering
with normal beating of the heart is a
risk
depending on your specific medical
condition there may be some risks not
listed here
leaking around the valve
damage to blood vessels
bleeding needing a blood transfusion
infection
emergency open heart surgery
electrical problem requiring a pacemaker
kidney damage from contrast dye
heart attack
stroke
death
ask your health care team for more
details
[Music]
med movie creator of the hx heart app an
easy to use visual storytelling tool for
healthcare professionals at the point of
care with images video and 3d models
med movie powerful visuals for health
and medicine